don't like uncomfortable things if I
bring it up no it's just another thing I
want to bring up he loves puncher it's
so dumb like when you and dr. Ken fought
in the green room possible and I've
talked about here for you there yeah it
was at Cobbs for suck it in his face oh
I've talked about it wait the actual
fistfight was honest like Bobby was
screaming and then Ken yeah there was a
little fish yeah yeah yeah but and you
know he's good eat my birthday last week
he he texted me happy birthday you
didn't but it's fine
did you and he spit in my face don't you
go lateral on this don't go lateral
anything from you give you stuff all I
know you do you really do
you're a good guy now didn't I let you
go through my water bottle to feel it
and I'm about to eat some of your walkie
I got you meet over there yeah yeah is
it a classy place your restaurant yeah
that's classy what do you mean it's it's
clean it's clean you like you're the
best you're an investor in yeah yeah big
time
is it off of the strip or where's it off
let's promote it what's it called it's
called Joe quois place no oh God be real
is that what it's called it's called yo
joke yo Jay yeah oh that's cool yeah
that's awesome so it's it's off the
strip it's right by my mom's place she
lives out in Summerlin area she worked
at nice areas my mom works there you
should really see how about well she
slices me oh that's amazing yeah yeah
and then I tell her to leave when the
the meats so this is you have enough
stocked you can go home this is a
family-run establishment that my mom
does not work there [ __ ] no why would
I apply what I have my mom's slicing
meat at the age of 71 you [ __ ] dick
she's retired
okay she walks in like us are Imelda
Marcos every clue
I thought she does when her son you're
sorry so sorry I'm gonna stand up again
yep take a stand
take a stand you [ __ ] [ __ ]
okay yes you fake mother [ __ ] I know
you something right now yes there's a
place called um what's a shabu-shabu
house in Little Tokyo it's the most
successful [ __ ] shabu place in LA and
the parents were right the guy that owns
it works slices the meat that yes
because he's an so I saw anybody yeah
but on the same can you saw it I'm like
okay I could believe that you [ __ ]
now now you know there's a difference
between that family and mine you won't
know the difference
yeah that guy has to [ __ ] work there
that's his paycheck whoa my mouth my you
know what I would [ __ ] you [ __ ] you let
me see this hey thanks for giving birth
to me and you know what 70th birthday
you're hired
go [ __ ] slice meat I wish you know
what I was upon you now you know what I
wish upon you only one week at these
comedy clubs okay all right no I want
you don't don't say that I want you to
you really are night I've always loved
you yeah
[Music]